welcome to this 15-minute game playing
hmm yyh to double 0 for 9 18 spoon okay
it's a relatively experienced account
but I never played him so let's see what
we get Kings Indian or groom fault k the
Kings Indian
don't know I mean there are many lights
but thinking about what to what to
choose let's serve let's try for the
classical and I could play the Petrosian
system yeah why not I mean this is
totally out of fashion that it's not a
bad line it has one important point I
have not cancelled I am it should be bd7
that's a slightly offbeat move but it's
not terribly bad i mean that's been
played by Kasparov at least once or
twice so it it's not that terrible night
h5 so he wants to go geoffroy I probably
should just play g3 and prevent that
lucky I think cannot play h 5m h 5 f-5
because of yeah more than one thing
actually Wow and okay 92 f six if I go
back to the two which is really like
normal and those pieces terribly
misplaced well what exactly are they
doing hmm I mean the yeah yeah but still
the night on h5 has nowhere to go if the
night of f6 move I take age 5
hmm but how do I continue still it's
c-5m just opening up or queen situ and
long long castles and then 94 as
possible so Quincy to is not good I also
can play f3 which is not bad controlling
g-form reliably g4 is bad do tonight f1
so we are getting their foot not sure
about c5 you might take c5 play rookie
aid
hmm I can also play okay ever play
Bishop f3 he might play Queen d7 now and
still go naija for moves like that
hmm
and this is probably still right I mean
it's the principled pawn break and are
taking I can take with the bishop john
just drop back to e3 it's still a good
structure and people normally think
black players are normally reluctant
here to take on c5 they normally let me
take so now i can take definitely and he
will take with the pawn which is
important so Nyjah form is in the mix
but still rooks u14 not behave it's
really irritating this move yeah I can I
can play that first
95 is so annoying it probably has to
react to it now so um
yeah f three years is not bad just
protecting g4 and preparing queen bee
three ideas maybe you can play Bishop g2
and queen age three Bishop g2 looks even
cleaner sherita's king of to trapping
the bishop okay that's good he might
play he can play 98 maybe and try to try
to play for f5 then yeah certainly I'm i
wonder if at some point Queen a4 might
be an idea just am trying to get the
Queen's off
yeah 98 of it it's quite quite logical
yeah Queen a4s queen e seven
there's some way to make a five less
attractive
what about now let's not not so
convincing not c4 not be five I was
thinking with it's not not really that
great
yawn I'd be five there's a sixer and I
just have to drop back leading to not
that much
Queen a for Queenie son not that's not
so great i mean i don't see a great
continuation then maybe a 449 be 5a 693
and the night c form he can play a 5 of
course but taking only for it's not an
issue and after F for Bishop f2 I think
I'm reasonably solid maybe after a 5km i
will start with this what I'm wondering
it's a little bit if he can take and go
for Bishop g2 and and Queen h3 these
kind of things maybe I must play rook g1
okay let's play rook g12 to prevent this
interesting he might play I exactly this
and I have to do this he can probably
take and play Bishop to h6 activating
his bishop okay yeah this this he
probably had to do otherwise i play g4g
it still feels at least for my for my
chest taste let's say it still feels
good for wide qui g5 coming but if I go
night see for Queen g5 Queen d2 i'm
going to i'm going to just trade queens
it does not help him at all when this is
the kind of position where the Queen
trade is almost almost a win for white
the d6 pawn is weak the whole Queen side
is weak so if i get to trade queens um
this would be simply tremendous um gee I
forgot about that move that that's you
good
why didn't I at least think about it I
was so focused on Queen g5 that I really
forgot that this is possible okay um
Roxy too it's not what I wanted to play
if he goes Queen g5 now this Bishop e3
but he can maybe sack the Queen that
that is really a possibility there
should be three Queenie 393 Bishop e3
assess huge probably for black the dark
squared Bishop is a monster getting to
deform so if he plays Queen g5 I'm not
going to play Bishop e3 it's not a
necessary move Bishop e3 he's not
threatening anything for the moment
night be five years getting this
activated
I didn't shake Bishop e7 and stuff like
that I mean it's not totally impossible
that that those moves I were were
playable but i didn't i didn't really
care that much ok i dropped back for a
585 and Knight b6 1 i'd be six
immediately he might we can maybe no
taking on f3 for Roxy for it's not
working rush very complicated stuff yeah
one issue is that Knight b6 is not
leading to that much with simply rook c7
where is he going maybe just for
defensive purposes
okay let's fix the queenside one Knight
b6 it was possible straight away but I
think a five is a move a useful mover
anyway in the long run k so on it's
their tactic Bishop g4 maybe for the f2
for the f2 Bishop play Knight b6 Brooks
is seven is probably glad about the rook
transfer to have some
should chief form
hmm
get this to f7 as well Jim c7 I thought
night night if I can t can play Bishop
g4
what do what this is a really annoying
should reform
and don't see how to cover that to be
totally honest
hmm
this intense night a 3 C 4 if I if you
please look at 7i Roxy 3 which keeps f3
protected ok and now officially fall
probably
No
not coming seems he wants to go to see
seven
I'm going to see for him
yeah he played this well it seems I must
have made some mistake I mean this whole
setup with night h5 when I df6 looks
really strange but and Quincy hate many
strange moves but I have made some
mistakes there definitely he has some
counter play and Bishop g4 is still a
move that I don't really know what what
to do against I mean yeah I mean what I
was thinking is that it is may be
possible to just give away the pawn and
I really don't see much else I mean
queen d3 let him take everything and
then sort of claim that the endgame is
serve is ok for me but this is this is
weird what a strange game yeah I have no
other move I mean have three years
hanging or what what else
the big big problem is that at the end
my e for par this week and this silly
age 59 returns to have 6m quite quite
unbelievable I really don't see how I
defend you for
Scott rook be 3m and then Knight f6 I
cannot defend the form
what did I do wrong here i don't i don't
understand it i really don't understand
what went wrong this opening is frankly
totally auntie positional what was wrong
I don't know after that she simply
outplayed me
now just night h to f6 and that's it if
is basically gone
don't really understand what he's
thinking about yeah this is a very
simple move yakking it to keeney to
maybe add that he was worried that kingi
to look b3 there might be some problem
with the rook but that's not the case
yeah I have to play that because simply
there is no move nobody move but he just
has rupee three
is there any any way to to do it you
have to even continue to play
it's amazingly bad position
after years taken before I really have
no move whatsoever
yeah trading doesn't look good I know
but he can even play route before which
is which is quite interesting or look b5
just claiming that his rook is the more
active piece anyway
now but this is the the simple move the
human booth Joe might as well resign
hemet chef maybe have some ideas on the
queenside I don't even have a way to
attack the the b7 porn since it's really
remarkably bad disposition b4 b5 I don't
really understand what I what I did
wrong there
really weird
really nothing to do em this is this is
a ticket
this move threatening my candy it's not
really a threat but maybe you have you
know what Bishop what what exactly is
going on here is Knight f6 it's not not
really optimal but is there some way to
use this he slightly tied down at the
moment not really it's really remarkably
bad
he has got many ways to win but just
never liked to resign never I still I
always have hope even if you need the
bleakest positions that there is some
some way to to screw it up but here it's
admittedly very difficult I don't get to
don't get to be 70 to it in some way at
least it's really not possible time
warning
and I still still still somewhat
somewhat arguing with myself what i want
i did there to screw the game up
what was what did I do wrong with Janet
c4 maybe or something I don't know Jeff
is nigh def whoa check now k maybe it
was lost anyway so night f1 check yeah
or this one
I Scott E to em and promotes
well come on white resigns yeah what the
game now it always feels bad i mean it
is this this is really just just bad
really really bad and I didn't extend
exploited
I mean this isn't good for white then
the Kings Indian must be the best
opening ever ever ever ever because I
mean I'm much better on the queenside
and the pieces are bungled up on the on
the King side so this what what did I do
wrong here queen bee three as a move
that the computer is recommending that's
actually interesting that took a very
long time here and then played a form
the idea of queen bee three years and an
idea that I didn't think of it all is
that after f5 white is night d 1 which
is quite interesting idea is to play
here and for Bishop f2 but this is not
this is quite quite similar to the game
diamond in the game I really don't think
that this should be should be good for
black anyway but what did I do wrong
yeah Bishop e3 here yeah there should be
three years though is the good news yeah
I suspected that this is wrong I didn't
really only thought about Queen g5 not
so much about this but even this is
debatable yeah well the computer is just
merciless Bishop a seven wins there is
nothing that you can do on the kingside
Bishop a seven plus 2m I didn't even
think about the move
I mean I was thinking that I should try
to just keep the Kings side I mean very
solid because I'm automatically winning
if I'm training Queens for example
that's why I did that put a six this is
not that great relief the night coming
to be six sir this is still better
probably than a form and rook h1 yeah
this is technical player exactly in a
moment where queen d 7 or c 8 is not
possible yeah yes to retreat and then a
five and now ever this is terrible for
black that's really terrible he does not
have any counter play now against f3
with those tactics just queen d 3 and so
on yeah that was good yeah I'd requires
precision I mean this is this is really
really questionable what what black
played but you have to be super precise
to exploited what I didn't do no it'd be
success yet another bad move this is
stronger the idea is that now Bishop e3
is strong
but it wasn't this possible in the game
may I played this move takes and this I
can play 92 now which I didn't this and
rook everyone was still okay because he
cannot take him hmm okay yeah I made
many mistakes really many many mistakes
this is this is basically giving up the
whole thing that was just a really bad
game yeah I mean this is really the the
clearest thing and that's it once you
see it and you see the computer
evaluation you really ask yourself what
exactly was it that that made me not
play this it's not just the pawn the
pawn is important but the b6 square is
now in my hands and where's the counter
player exact name is is just winning
nothing more nothing less of course he
can can muddy the waters in typical
Kings Indian style but this is just
happening in many of those lines yeah
just bad bad play okay thanks for
watching